colombia vivió una nueva jornada de
tensión tras una semana de protestas en
las calles eeuu la unión europea y la
onu rechazaron el uso excesivo de la
fuerza al margen de las manifestaciones
que nacieron en rechazo al proyecto de
reforma tributaria de iván duque y que
tras su retiro derivaron en un reclamo
por igualdad social y en rechazo a la
violencia policial las organizaciones
sociales que desde el pasado miércoles
movilizan a miles de personas en todo el
país salieron a las calles para exigir
garantías constitucionales a la protesta
la desmilitarización de las ciudades y
una negociación con el gobierno sobre el
sistema de salud y la renta básica entre
otros puntos ante el escalamiento de las
tensiones el presidente colombiana
anunció la instalación de una mesa de
diálogo nacional para encontrar una
salida pacífica que instalaremos un
espacio para escuchar a la ciudadanía y
construir soluciones orientado a estos
propósitos en los cuales no deben mediar
diferencias ideológicas sino nuestro más
profundo patriotismo
en este espacio es vital contar con
todas las instituciones los partidos el
sector privado gobernadores alcaldes y
líderes de la sociedad civil motivadas
por el servicio a la ciudadanía los
casos de brutalidad policial divulgados
a través de redes sociales despertaron
la alerta para la comunidad
internacional dada la situación
extremadamente tensa con soldados y
policías desplegados para vigilar la
protesta pedimos calma recordamos a las
autoridades estatales su responsabilidad
de proteger los derechos humanos
incluido el derecho a la vida y la
seguridad de la persona y de facilitar
el ejercicio del derecho a la libertad
de reunión pacífica artistas y
deportistas colombianos también han
condenado el uso desproporcionado de la
fuerza para controlar la protesta social
las páginas web del ejército del senado
y la presidencia de colombia fueron
pirateadas además el grupo de hackers
anonymous publicó una lista de correos y
contraseñas de miembros del ejército